Hi and welcome back to another VC libraries.
Open code review.
Today we'll be looking at a PR,
a very large one from Casey Carter
and the PR will be number 2806
implementing paper P 1206 R 7
conversions from ranges to containers.
Let me go ahead and share my screen.
So here is the PR we'll be
looking at 2806 UM, as usual, uh,
we have a tracking issue that's this
12532 that links to the paper itself
and mentions the feature test macro
values as we're finally decided
for the CPS working paper and I
have brought up the paper itself.
Some context here is we are trying to
implement all of the C23 papers that
have been voted in so far to the standard.
Here's our status chart.
This is since we went open source or
I can click on more history to get
the entire recorded history since mid
2017 when we started keeping track.
So currently we are at six C + + 23
library features remaining to be implemented.
And once we get this, uh,
paper merged, we'll be down to five.
So every time this line ticks
down from 6 to 5 and so forth,
that's a major accomplishment.
Even though it looks like it's
just a very small amount and we're
trying to remain clean.
You can see this sort of zigzag,
especially if I focus on just C + 23.
This sort of sawtooth pattern every
time the committee votes and stuff,
we go and implement it merge a lot of
things for our from our contributors,
then the committee votes and more stuff.
And by trying to remain clean and
getting down to close to zero before
the committee votes and more stuff,
we don't develop a huge backlog,
which is what happened during
the CS plus 20 era,
as we're getting better and better
at implementing features rapidly.
So it's great to see that Casey has
implemented this paper that he Co authored.
It is however.
A very large PR and a very large paper.
Uh,
if we look at the PR it's over 7000 lines.
A lot of its test code,
but it's not entirely test
code and the feature itself.
I was just scrolling down to the
bottom and this is an 86 page paper,
so this is actually a relatively large
feature authored by quarantine jabat,
Eric Niebler and Casey Carter,
and I am vaguely familiar
with what the paper is doing,
but not entirely,
so I'll be spending a little bit of time.
Reading this paper uh on the video code
review and mentioning my thoughts before
we delve into the code and so forth.
Uh, OK, so to start with Umm, let's see.
I think this is big enough.
I'm at 1:50.
Zoom Casey has an excellent change log here.
This is something that's
greatly appreciated in PQRS,
where you know we have the tracking
issues so we can see what it's doing.
But it's also helpful to have
a guide to what
files are being changed.
So here Casey's broken it up by
each individual header that's
being modified and the test that.
That are being modified and so forth.
So if I'm ever confused about
like why changes are happening,
especially changes to internal
machinery that should be answered
by this change log here,
so I won't go ahead and read all of this,
but I will consult this if necessary.
If I'm wondering, hey,
you know why is this being changed
or you know was something missing?
I can go back and check this.
There's even notes about.
Proposed resolutions for library
working group issues that have been
implemented because our general
rule is we implement what's been
voted into the C Plus working paper.
But if we do anything that's not yet
official, it is very helpful to know
that that's being done intentionally,
rather than just going off and doing a bunch
of wild stuff because we think it's right.
OK, so let's quickly read the paper and
then I will actually start looking at
the code so the structure of a paper.
In case you're not familiar,
it UM often has a change log
for the paper itself,
as the paper is revised.
And I will Scroll down here past
that change log.
There's a very convenient overview.
I guess I'm highlighting here that
explains what this is adding,
so there's going to be a function
ranges 2 and it will take a range,
which is that stuff that was added in C
+ 20 and we'll turn it into a container.
It'll materialize it as a container
and it'll work with non standard
containers and recursive containers.
I don't know those are yet,
but we'll see below.
Hopefully,
and it also adds tagged constructors and
assert and assigned member functions
for standard containers and strength.
So there's a bunch of example usage here.
This might be a little small to see.
Maybe I can step zoom one.
OK, here we go.
So here's a nice motivating example.
We've got stood views IOTA one through 10,
so this is gonna count the
numbers one through 10.
I believe that is inclusive here.
And this range can then be fed
to other algorithms or views,
and we can operate on that.
But this iota view does not actually
physically store the numbers one
through 10 anywhere in memory.
It's sort of generating them on demand,
as I understand it.
So if we actually want a vector of this,
we will now be able,
and C + 23 to say ranges 2 stood for
int and that will turn it into a
vector and a bunch of other examples here.
I can Scroll down,
UM ohh I see nested ranges like
a list of forward list.
So if I have a list of forward list
I can convert that into a vector
vector int by saying ranges 2.
This is cool.
We didn't used to be able to
do this directly.
You could do one level by range constructing
a vector using first and last iterators,
but converting multiple levels was
not possible this conveniently,
so that's quite nice.
Umm,
these before and after tables.
We should really not be called Tony
tables because that's a bit of W 21
insider jargon name for Tony Van Eerd,
who's a committee member?
Who's popularized these very
useful before and after tables
is just the name is inscrutable,
and then some design notes
on why this is designed.
So if you've never read
a standard paper before,
this is actually quite useful
to understand why a feature
has been proposed the way it has,
and I will skip over this.
Since I've got at least a
basic idea of what's going on,
I did want to jump here I'm talking about.
Why the constructors and the Member
functions have tax A tag type is an empty.
I guess I can open my editor here.
So. Close this, actually,
I guess actually I can even show you
CP reference on piecewise construct.
Here we go. OK, so piecewise construct,
which goes back to C + 11 is an
example of a standard tag type.
The the C + 9803 had some tags like uh.
Input iterator tag forward iterator
tag that we used for tag dispatch.
Piecewise construct is a little bit
different because it's actually
used for actual constructions.
You can take a pair and say I
have a pair of A&amp;BI would like to
construct the A&amp;B elements of this
pair in place from arbitrary stuff.
Piecewise construct is a tie or piecewise
construct is an object of a type
piecewise construct and it's stateless.
It has no.
Actual use at runtime.
It exists only to select
a certain constructor,
because constructors can't have names.
But if you have a constructor
taking this empty type,
that's like giving it a name.
It's A tag constructor.
That's the unofficial way to refer to it.
So, piecewise construct lets you say,
hey, I want to call.
I want to construct a pair from a
couple of tuples and then crack open
the tuples and use their arguments to
individually individually construct
the A&amp;B and we have to do that.
And construction time.
We don't want to go assign them later,
so that's what piecewise construct does.
There's other tag types that have
been added to cplus over the years.
A couple more I can think of
are was it in place index and T?
And there's also in place.
T Yeah,
so if you're constructing an optional
variant or any you can use in place
in place type or in place index to
say I want to construct this thing
at this index or of this type.
And the tag not only tells you,
it tells the library which
constructor you want,
but it can also provide additional like
type information or index information.
So we're sort of retrofitting kind of
constructor names through this tag machine,
so going back to 1206 revision 7,
this is talking about why do we
need A tag for these constructors?
So let's see the answer.
Here is an example class template
argument deduction if you have a
list you try to construct a vector.
Are you going to get a vector of list of int?
And that's what CTAD currently does.
And if you use A tag,
you'll be able to say I want to convert
this list of int into a vector of int.
Other examples where any absorbs types.
And different names will
resolve ambiguities there,
so that's why this has been
designed the way it has been.
OK,
so let me Scroll down to the
actual proposed wording.
There's benchmarks here,
and all sorts of things like that.
Implementation experience I guess
the paper is not actually 85
pages of wording.
It's only like 75 pages of wording.
Proposed wording OK.
So this is a guide to yeah Kate
Casey's laughing because he's the one
who helped write all of this stuff.
I guess I should be happy that it is
shorter than the original range proposal,
so this wording is relative to a slightly
older draft of the working paper and 4885.
I do have the current one and
4910 since as far as I'm aware
this has not been further patched,
at least significantly in 4910.
I am going to be just looking at the
original paper. This is because.
It's updating a lot of wording in place,
so I can't just look at like
a newly added section.
Excuse me in the standard.
For, uh,
what this is I could cross cross reference,
but that's a lot slower,
so I'm just going to be looking at this,
but keeping in mind that if anything
has been patched in the standard,
that could be a potential bug.
The nice thing about having a PR written
by a Co author of the paper is that
that author Casey is presumably aware of.
If this wording has been patched later
and would have incorporated that,
so I'm not too concerned about missing
last minute changes that have been applied,
but if this PR were being authored by.
Somebody other than an original paper author,
and if it had been a lot more time since
the PR had been merged into the working
paper versus when we were reviewing it,
the chance for the chance for Divergance
where the wording was further altered in
the working draft and would be higher,
and I would need to be much more
careful about double checking the
latest working paper and making
sure that it's wording is actually
what is being implemented.
OK, so that's enough preamble, uh,
let's go ahead and start reviewing this.
I'll be mainly focusing on the
product code because the test code
is extremely voluminous.
I might take a little bit look
at the test code,
so let's see if I can split these windows.
OK, let's get rid of this working draft here.
Let's move this over here, OK?
Only 117 files changed.
OK alt Click to minimize all of the.
Files that they'll cooperate.
OK,
so the product code is not
actually 7000 lines.
UM, there is a lot of tests being added.
Push range from range and so forth,
rather than just adding a single mega test.
OK, excuse me wow that is.
OK. So let me take a look at
the centralized stuff first.
That is a lot of it.
It's, uh, that's test.
I'm looking at OK.
So we've got a new paper comment being
added here because we record C + 23 features.
This is indeed P 1206 R 7 conversions
from ranges to containers matching
our cleaned up paper title.
It is in sorted order under 23.
That's good. We now have a little
bit of white space difference there.
I could ignore white space.
Why don't I do that?
Gonna click on where is it file?
No not file filter.
Is because my window is tiny.
I think it's under the gear.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
I was I was a little confused because the
window was tinier than I usually work in,
so it's like where?
Where is the UI that I usually click?
OK, there we go.
Now we're ignoring white space
and I'll re minimize again.
Why? Plus core great.
Still not realized. There we go.
Oops, I don't want to maximize everything.
OK, so probably six or seven
conversions ranges to containers.
UM, claim formats indenting expected,
which is the change I didn't want to see,
so here.
We're adding one of the
new feature test macros,
CPP Lib containers ranges.
These are separate because in
theory they're like two different
things being added at the same time.
They could also in theory
be implemented separately,
but they're being implemented simultaneously,
which is great.
So we've got the new feature test macro.
It is this one is guarded by CPP
Lib concepts because ranges is
typically constrained by concepts,
so that is expected.
It has got the right spelling.
It's got the right value on February 2022,
which is when this was voted in
and then this is in sorted order.
Con S followed by con T and
then expected that's good.
And then the other one is
range is 2 container.
Yep also guarded by concepts S
before T good sorted order and.
Standard value yes,
and nothing else needs to
change in rivals core.
We're not adding any deprecation
messages or anything.
That's good.
We can also jump on over to
the feature test macro test,
get that out of the way.
King spellings all of them are being updated.
They have the same value here.
So Yep, that's all good.
They are guarded here.
I'm just checking with their guarded by
their CSS 23 and not EDG because EDG does
not yet fully support concepts for us.
Yep, that's the right transition message.
These are also in sorted order
con escon T Co routine Yep.
And then ranges 2 container ranges
as ranges T raw memory algorithms.
Yep, that looks good.
Feature test macro test is updated.
Uh, mentally thinking.
Is there anything else that
we need to update?
No, because we're not adding
a new header or anything.
So in that respect this feature is simple.
OK, so let's take a look at the product code.
OK, there's some changes to algorithm.
I would actually like to
look at the description here.
So in algorithm, UM.
Promote get final iterator unwrapped
to X utility from algorithm and
then add more stuff to X utility.
OK so code is moving around.
I love to double check code movements
because that is a wonderful time
for things like merge conflicts
and other bugs to be introduced.
So algorithm simply removing this code.
What I'm going to do because the built
in Dev doesn't handle this is I'm
going to copy that over to my editor.
And I will handle comments.
Remember what this is?
This is old from algorithm.
OK, then we're gonna go over since that's
the only change and check X utility.
And see if we can find the new code.
Uh, well it looks like it's here.
OK, make sure the context is the same.
We're clearly within 20 because
we're mentioning range of stuff,
but we're not specifically within 23,
so the context is good.
And let's copy paste over here.
This is new from actually utility.
There's the code is that the
same level of indent? It is OK?
So then I'm just gonna dip them.
And there are no differences.
Wonderful, so it's pure code movement,
nothing else being introduced, perfect.
OK. So I trust that edit.
And we've got some other
centralized changes here.
I think I do want to review the
centralized changes before getting
into the per container changes,
so move this over here.
OK, so we're in X utility and X utility
in addition to promoting UM and copy
memmove N and copy and unchecked.
Similar to copy memmove and copy unchecked,
but for counted ranges.
Generalized inter copycat
to Sentinel copycat.
OK, so actually tility.
We've got a drive by cleanup here
fusing together namespace ranges.
We were just closing it and reopening it.
That's totally fine.
We can handle a little bit of
drive by cleanup in feature work,
especially if it's innocuous like
that it was a larger I would
ask for it to be separated out.
OK, so here is the.
Copying memmove N for counted ranges,
so we need a contiguous
iterator and the size to count.
OK, so let's take a look here.
In the context we can see we
originally had a copy memmove,
as I recall. I think it was our
contributor Adam Busier who.
I extracted this and polished it up, uh,
because previously we had a more like,
uh or more special purpose version of this,
and this is now appropriately generalized.
So that was a very nice clean up and
we now need a different version of it,
because sometimes we have a
contiguous iterator and account but
not two contiguous iterators and.
Why can't we simply synthesize a final one?
Is it purely for micro optimization?
Because if we if we believe that
we can do memmove.
And we can convert to addresses.
It really seems like.
We could implement one in terms of
the other if we weren't just calling
like move and we had to do some,
you know, arbitrary operation,
then calling one in terms of the
other might not be possible.
It might not be efficient,
so let's see if I can answer this myself.
We confirmed the address,
we do a bunch of cons casting.
OK, so the difference here is that
we can get the byte count by just
multiplying the count of elements.
We multiply that by the size of an
element that gives us the number
of bytes to mimic if we.
Implemented this in terms of copying memmove.
We would essentially be doing pointer
arithmetic or a multiplication and an
addition to get the last contiguous
iterator for pointer and then doing
a subtraction to get the count.
Here we can sort of bypass that
we still need to synthesize.
No,
we don't need to because copy member
we actually just wants the account so.
In theory, it's very very slightly less work.
We're avoiding an addition and subtraction,
UM,
but this that subtraction is just
in terms of bytes anyways.
We did really care about micro performance
when we worked on the original copy memo.
That's actually why it's so careful too.
Once we've got the bytes.
Once we we what we do is we separately
convert first to a pointer to care
and last two pointer to care and
then we can directly subtract them.
We don't need to jump from the bite
domain to the element domain and back
then move once a number of bytes,
so we can just subtract the byte pointers.
That was important there I'm less
convinced it's important here.
OK, I, I will now call my lifeline Casey.
What are your thoughts on why this is
a separate function instead of simply
wrapping or just directly calling?
You know copy memo?
Was it purely for micro performance?
It seemed really important to me at the time,
but now I can't seem to recall why.
Yeah, it must just be for micro optimization.
I can't see any other reason for it.
OK, yeah, my feeling is like multiply.
Yeah, saving us anything major like the
way we save our division from from doing
whatever pointer difference from the
other case for copy member. Yeah yeah,
because the original one was if we.
Subtracted the the original
optimization we applied here was.
If we subtracted the original pointers,
we do a pointer.
We do pointer arithmetic,
which is a division by a constant
value to get from number of
bytes to number of elements,
and it is a constant division.
But if you divide by like 12 or 13 or
whatever horrible size the element is,
the compiler will have to emit a
bunch of magic multiplies and shifts,
and it's potentially slow.
When all we actually need is just
by subtraction.
So yeah, if we really wanted to
kind of bytes in the 1st place,
it's it's unfortunate.
Yeah,
it was purely wasted work and
it was reasonable.
Like we're avoiding a number
of optimizations,
and we're only going to have one function
that's called by a bunch of the STL.
We may as well devote a bunch
of time to developer time to
getting it really efficient,
but that's already been done here here.
At most,
this would be avoiding like a subtraction
and addition and an optimizer actually
probably can see through that.
Or even if it doesn't,
it's one subtraction 1.
Addition.
I'm thinking this should probably just
be implemented in terms of the other one.
Unless we ever find through like you know,
profiling that it's a big deal and then
we can go essentially restore this code,
but this seems like it's sort of duplicating
the amount of code we need to maintain and.
I'm less enthusiastic about that.
Especially if you can no longer remember
any specific motion request from the
author that they justify the existence
of this separate thing or get rid of it.
That sounds good. OK, I will add that.
Umm, OK so uh, let's see.
Because we're working with
contiguous iterators, this could
be implemented. By calling.
Happy man move.
Of Umm
the there might be. A.
Alright. If we did that,
there might be a little bit
of unnecessary work pointer.
A dish or I'll just say
addition, subtraction.
But nothing.
But there shouldn't be any significant
expense like a division by size of T.
Can you either justify?
The need for.
Near duplicating the code here
due to performance considerations.
Or simplify this by implementing.
Copying my move N in terms of. Copy memo.
OK, uh, because we're working
with contiguous iterators.
This could be implemented by copy
remove above if we did that,
there might be a little bit of
unnecessary work addition, subtraction,
but there shouldn't be any significant
expense like a division by size of T.
Can you either justify the need
for near duplicating code here due
to performance considerations?
Or simplify this by implementing copy
remove in in terms of copy memo?
OK. Uh, that said,
I see no specific correctness concerns here.
UM, we translate 1st and deaths to putters.
Just like above, we cast them over.
This looks exactly copy pasted.
The characters we got to do a little
dance to prospect constant and volatile.
That's all the same.
Uh, we already have a bite count and
I very much appreciate that this
is phrased in terms of byte count,
because it's bytes a top way we get
confused is just saying count or size.
When we variously mean like elements
or bytes.
By following the STL naming conventions,
if we ever see like counter length
or whatever,
we assume elements always in terms of
elements only if something specifically
says bytes are we dealing with bytes.
So this naming is good.
So we would take count times the size
of whatever do our first putter is,
so that's how we just get the element type.
That's fine,
we costed memmove with the byte count,
Yep, destinations first and then
we resent the size.
OK, so if we do need this function.
This is all correct.
Yeah, we had the bite count there otherwise.
Let's see here.
We already have the count,
so we static cast back to the.
Iterative type of the contiguous iterator.
The out contiguous iterator.
Yeah, so if we need this function,
this implementation is correct.
OK,
Next up I'm copy and unchecked,
uh, this is being added similar to
copy unchecked.
OK,
so this one is different than the
one we just looked at because it is
taking an arbitrary input iterator.
So the same concern of can we
just implement in terms of the
other one that does not apply,
so we actually do need this one?
As far as I can tell.
This looks like an edit,
but it's really just moving this
code down here and then there's
some generalization down here.
OK, so. We have copy and unchecked.
Has the same sort of signature,
but we take a size T count.
Always size T because that's.
That's interesting.
Why does copying insist on size T?
Usually it's like some sort
of iterative city thing.
Difference type sometimes UM.
That's quite interesting.
We do pass to copy memory,
but of course that one has a
reason to insist on size T.
But for the arbitrary 1.
It it is pathological that you'd
have to be on like a 32 bit system
and you somehow have a 64 bit count,
that's not gonna end well.
Well, no, it's an input iterator.
Or I'm sorry it's it's writing to
some arbitrary output iterator.
In theory, there's nothing stopping
you from copying like a file.
With this saying I want to copy
5 gigabytes from a file iterator
to an output file iterator.
Here's 5 billion.
That would truncate on X86 or 32 bit.
This seems highly suspicious.
I don't know if I like that.
I wanna look at the usage,
so let me actually, uh,
I'm going to to do a global
search in my editor.
I've got my repo here, so I'm going
to check out using the GitHub CLI.
What is this 2806 GHP R checkout do that.
Great, I should have upgraded this.
Here we go.
OK so I'm gonna look for all
occurrences of copy on and checked.
I love global search.
OK, so here's the implementation
we're looking at.
We have internal usages here.
What is new size?
I care about the type of new size.
New size is the size type.
So this is an arbitrary size type.
Coming from a sign counted range,
let's just continue spelunking and see if
we can find where this is coming from.
Uhm, count.
That's a size type from the allocator.
That's a vector allocator, but again,
this is all this is assigning to a vector.
We're not just copying arbitrary iterators,
so a vector really does need
to store its stuff in memory.
OK, so maybe assign counter range.
This one's fine.
This doesn't have the same concern.
It is highly suspicious though.
Let me go back to count copy and checked.
The other one is in insert range.
OK, so with the specific usage here.
It seems like we're OK because
we're actually copying into memory,
but this does have the flavor of a.
An algorithm that looks
like it's general purpose,
but it has special case assumptions
and I view that as hazardous.
I would be much more comfortable if this,
uh, some sort of you know, size, type.
If this is ever used, it doesn't even know
it has colors outside the copy family.
They happen to be within the vector family.
But yeah, I think I think I want to
ask that there needs to be some sort
of difference type and then it's
when we call copy memory when that.
At that point,
we know that copy memmove and gets to
use size T because once we get this
handwritten type trait selling OK,
telling us hey,
these iterators are really raw pointers,
and the thing we point to is trivial.
Everything's in memory.
Have fun once we know it's in memory size,
it's totally appropriate.
It's when we don't know stuff is in memory,
we really should be working with
the original arbitrary type.
That or this should be prominently
commented saying hey,
this is really size T what are
you doing at a minimum,
also compiler warnings,
because we've dutifully converted
within vector all of our stuff
to size under score type.
But then here we just call it
implicitly and pass it to a size T.
So size T is tiny and size
under score type is big like.
Vector with an allocator or
the 64 bit size type on X86.
Admittedly unusual.
We get a compiler warning,
so I think from a compiler warning standpoint
and a minimum, this needs to be changed.
OK, so this is hard coded to take size T,
But it's being called with.
Or called by vector with a
potentially custom.
Size type to avoid compiler warnings.
At a minimum.
It seems that this should also.
Be generalized.
Not sure if size type the.
In its.
Difference type.
Etcetera is the most appropriate here.
Here I can just leave this to Casey
because as it ranges expert he will
know exactly which type he is and I
don't have to think too hard about it.
For example, I know that C + + 17
input writers don't necessarily
have a different type. There you go,
so different type would be a bad choice.
Yeah, arbitrary integer type is
probably what we want to allow here,
and that would be just fine.
To an arbitrary integer. Type. Yeah.
OK, this is hard coded takes
ice T but it's being called by
vector with potential custom size
type to avoid prior warnings.
At a minimum it seems that this
should also be generalized to
an arbitrary integer type.
I will add the note once we
determine that the MEM meow memmove
optimization is applicable,
it's safe to static cast to size T.
OK.
OK, so questioning every single identifier
we've got size 2 there. OK comment copy.
Interesting how this is price copy under
score first plus inclusive 0 count
exclusive to dust plus inclusive 0 count
exclusive returning dust plus count no
test callers outside the copy family.
OK, if constexpr it or copycat
here is just utter because all we
have is in and out at bit.
Copy assignable.
Let me just check the argument order here.
I think that's right because it's
copy pasted, but can't be too sure.
Yeah, we give it source and destination,
so that's good source is in it.
Destinations out it if it's a bit
copy assignable then context for 20.
If we're in has 620 mode.
If we're not constant valuated,
we can do cool thing.
Umm yeah, this is the right.
This is the right way to test it.
We've got this sort of dance that we
do that if we're eligible at all at
compile time for the optimization
then we will see if we need to
defend against constant evaluation.
So in 20 mode this function
needs to be constexpr,
so we will be able to call
also constant evaluated and if
we're not constant evaluated,
meaning we're runtime, we can call memmove.
If we are constantly evaluated,
we'll skip over that and do the hand.
The classic loop.
And if we're not in 20 mode at all,
if we're 17 or below that,
we don't need to worry about being constexpr.
We can just on conditioning call this thing.
So this is the right order.
The right structure.
We have this pattern elsewhere.
Otherwise, do the classic loop.
We've got a void cast here to defend
against overloaded commas on both sides.
Yeah, that's all just copy paste
from the original stuff,
so that's all good. OK.
Next up, so we've got a Sentinel copycat.
This is BA.
This is the generalized form that is
implemented in terms of inter copycat
but with extra spicy stuff here.
Template on class INIT class
Sentinel class outit using Sentinel
copy category is conditional T,
so we're going to ask a question
if we're in CPU Lib Concepts mode,
because this is unconditionally defined,
but if we're in concepts mode,
we're gonna ask.
Is the Sentinel the same as the
input iterator then? That's good.
We're we're potentially eligible.
Or even if the Sentinel is not
the same as the input iterator.
If it's a sized Sentinel 4,
then we can determine the size and
constant time and engage the optimization.
So that's what happens when
you have concept support.
But if we don't have concept support,
we can't detect high Sentinel,
so we can we have to restrict
ourselves to just the Sentinel being
the same as the input iterator.
Then we call it our copycat.
Otherwise it is. False, trivial cap.
What is this?
OK, it says false for both big
copy constructable and big copy.
Assignable it's like double falls.
UM OK, so that seems good.
My one question is do we have to
worry because this is is same V is
same V as a standard type trait.
It is extremely specific, it only wants
the types to be exactly identical.
It does not want any divergent CV qualifiers
or top level references or anything.
So if users of Inter copycat could
potentially be passing like.
Constant the top of a constant iterators.
UM, if ITER copycat tolerated,
that but Sentinel copycat doesn't,
then that would be an issue.
So let me look at.
Uses of it are copycat.
I'm still with the branch checked out.
So, whoops.
Here you first OK, we do usually
call it with something modifiable,
but there is the potential for it
to be consequ qualified if we ever
had a couple of accounts there.
I'm just looking at usages first and
I'll look at the actual definition.
Definition of bitter copycat.
Ask things like iterators or
contiguous iterator nonvolatile.
It gets the value type.
I think here. Do we remove?
Do we remove top all consonants?
This is something we always have
to worry about in our handwritten
type traits like do we care
about tobacconists or not?
Or is the definition of this? Here we go.
We use inter value T and Constance mode.
Otherwise we ask iterator traits.
Iterator traits does have a specialization
that ignores top level cost as I recall.
Have this code review is just you know me
trying to remember how the standard works.
Her specializations it's for Tye star.
Where's the one with whom we have
the table of contents intercore.
This is actually where we're
implementing iterator traits are we
not ignoring tuple of accounts here?
Don't believe so. OK, so OK.
So this really does it wants
non constant qualified. OK.
OK, so that indicates that UM,
inter copycat does not really want
to see top of a constant iterators.
It already would have a problem there,
so we don't need to worry
about the Sentinel copycat.
OK, so that's good.
Otherwise we're back to copy and check,
but this is being generalized.
It used to insist on in.
At last it's now taking a Sentinel.
The order of the template parameters
matches the function parameters,
which is good.
OK here uh, let's make sure that
the comments are still valid.
Copy first to last exclusive to desk dot OK,
use the Sentinel copycat.
Past the Sentinel OK?
Same that cost evaluate guard.
And then if we're in concepts mode.
We need to additionally require.
That in it be the same as the Sentinel,
because it could just be
that it's a size Sentinel.
But if we're in no concepts mode,
then the only way we could have gotten
here is for them to be the same.
We may as well as still
internal static assert that.
Otherwise, I see if your signal
you dispatch to the other one.
OK. This is really trying to
avoid repeating copy memo,
but it jumps in and out of
concepts checks here and here.
It's all confusing, but it's OK.
Otherwise people have concepts.
The only way to get here
should really be Sentinel 4.
Then we can do the copy and move in.
OK with first.
Last minus first here static cast size
is fine because we know we're eligible.
And then dust. OK. That's fine.
Is there any better way to do this?
I don't see one.
Do we need this first?
Static assert here.
This one here we're static
starting with the same type, but.
Synt copycat I don't think we could get here.
We couldn't get through sent copycat if they
were different types in non concepts mode.
Right, what about Sentinel 4?
In non concepts mode right?
This is non concepts.
You would concept is not defined.
Yeah. Have similar concepts.
Not to find additional if there are different
types that conditional is going to pick,
the false type is going
to pick false trivial cat,
in which case bit copy
assignable will be false.
So this static assert cannot fail.
It's completely redundant.
Yeah, well, I mean that that's what that's
what the internal static series for,
because this one is also redundant in theory,
right?
Fair enough, yeah, so now.
The thing is,
it does complicate the flow here
because you need the whole else.
I'm not sure if I'm I'm not
sure if it's worth it like.
This probably made sense
while I was developing,
but I don't really want to check that in.
Yeah,
yeah,
mostly because I mean we we do
semester internal static certs.
That's good when verifying connections
between like farflung code.
In this case you're just sort
of verifying the trait that
you defined immediately above.
I don't. I think that actually
harms clarity, and I think this one
probably is not necessary either.
And then this would be easier to read.
Yeah, because we wouldn't need to
think there's no concepts case.
Yeah, but I think this would be much more
readable without the internal source.
OK, so sure you have one comment
that extends both of them.
Sure I can. I can do that.
The external static certs here.
Don't seem to be especially valuable.
UM, as? There related to the type trait.
That's the internal type trait.
That's defined immediately above.
Eliminating them would.
Improve the readability of
this code with no significant.
Law or no significant potential for danger.
They asked internist. Experts here
don't seem to be especially valuable,
as they're related to the internal type
trait that's defined immediately above.
Limiting them would improve the
readability of this code with no
significant potential for danger.
So background here is that this
highly ugly macro is defined only
for our internal test suite.
The idea here is that if we want to static
assert something for our purposes only,
saying that if we got this wrong,
it's a logic error in the STL itself.
This should never happen, because STL.
Umm, implementers are awesome and our
code is highly reviewed and we never,
ever make bugs.
But in the rare event that it does,
we would like to test that only
in our internal test suite.
It should.
Preprocess away to nothing for users
because we don't want to spend extra
throughput time verifying all this
stuff that should always be true,
so that's what the still
internal static assert does,
and there's a place in our machinery.
This thing expands to Stack Cert only when
enable STL internal check is defined,
and this is defined only for our test suite.
Somewhere we have that where do we do this?
It's probably not whole board slash D.
Here we go.
In our tests we have a compiler.
Uh, set of compiler options,
and we define enable STL internal check for
our test only everybody else not defined,
so it expands to nothing.
Uhm?
Because we're not asserting
anything about the users code,
it's purely internal.
So yeah,
I think we can drop that.
OK, so if they are for
concepts, if it's the same.
OK and then. If they're the
same I'm I'm trying to think
what happens if both are true.
If the types are the same and
the and it's the size Sentinel,
well that's that's always going to be
the case, because if you're eligible,
you're like contiguous iterator,
so it had better be a size Sentinel.
Refer the copy memmove 1.
Because we gotta subtract anyways and.
This one is better when between
the two forms,
because this can subtract byte pointers,
so it doesn't do that.
Vision we're entire division by
constant and then multiplication,
whereas if we have Sentinel 4,
this one does have to potentially
do that pointer arithmetic,
so it is proper to prefer this one.
So I like.
OK yeah,
whenever I see control flow I'm like OK.
What happens if both the conditions are true?
OK, continuing onward, uh,
we've got get final iterator unwrapped.
This was the thing that was
promoted from utility.
We saw that it's exactly unchanged,
so skip skip, skip down to copy.
Unchecked, we are generalizing.
We used to check if.
ITER copycat is big copy,
assignable and recite something before.
And now that's going into Sentinel copycat.
Is that ideal?
Yes, because the Sentinel copycat.
Allow site Sentinel 4 to also activate it.
Previously we insisted on
them being the same.
Uh, because if we are. Hold on.
Here we were specific.
We said it has to be a Sentinel four.
Ohh because we did copy memmove
and we synthesize final now as long
as Sentinel Copycat returns true,
we can call either the copy my move or
the copy move in and we have both paths.
OK, so this seems right.
We're not as worried that we're
like changing the optimization
activated in cases where it's not,
but we're not.
As long as Sentinel copycat holds.
And this one says.
Either we can find the last
iterator or they're the same,
then ask it or copycat OK?
And we'll handle both cases below because
we do have to handle the unsized.
Sentinel 4 yeah, that's the difference.
Previously we insisted
on size Sentinel 4 now.
We'll handle the case where it's not
a size kennel, but they are the same
and they otherwise are eligible.
It actually seems like perhaps we
we were overly insistent here.
Oh, that's right, we weren't, UM?
No, we we did need this.
The issue was what if copy and checked?
Have some Sentinel.
That's like unbounded or something or.
What if it's a Sentinel that only inspects
the element type so it's not sized UM?
We required it required it to be sized here,
otherwise we were just
ignoring the Sentinel entirely.
I remember this came up in a code review,
possibly a video code review,
so that's why we had to check it here.
But what if now?
We are passing it to Sentinel copycat
so here we say either the iterator and
the Sentinel need to be the same type.
So we do care about the Sentinel type
there or it has to be size Sentinel four.
OK so we aren't just ignoring
the Sentinel here.
We are properly activating either
in this case or in the case we're
the same because being the same.
Is essentially stronger than.
Site Sentinel four.
When the bid copy SIGNABLE is true.
OK, so this is good.
We're not losing anything.
OK, so then this code is changing because
we now need to handle the two cases.
What if you're the same versus?
What if your size Sentinel?
For if if Constexpr is saying VI T&amp;C then.
We can just call, copy, move directly.
We don't need to do this ranges next thing
because we know they're the same type,
so we can call copayment, move, move first.
We can pass last directly.
We don't want to move from because
we're going to move from it down
there and then move result.
Update result and then move it out here.
That's good, otherwise they're not the same,
but size Sentinel 4.
Here the stone turning static
assert is appropriate.
We should stack assert that
is a size Sentinel 4.
It's arguable how much
even this is necessary.
It is far flung like this is many,
many lines down, so I don't object to it.
The thing is, we do actually
just subtract right here,
so if it wasn't a size Sentinel 4
this would totally fail to compile.
But it's reasonable to have
that internal stack, Sir,
which is sort of a reminder to us that hey,
we checked this, it was hidden
within the sent copycat type trait.
That's why we know this code is valid,
so I like that and it vanishes for users.
So we subtract last minus first.
We know we're. Bit copy signable
so it had better be a size T.
That's the count we can go copy my move in.
1st. Why are we not moving first here?
Because we need to update it.
Past the count that we just got.
Discount could be consed we don't
modify this and stood move result.
OK, so first we need update count should be
constant remove result we update result.
We step first by count because
that's what we need to return.
Then we move it out, move it out.
OK, so this is just the constant.
Count. Could be confused.
OK, and then finally the end of
X utility. We are in copy end.
OK, we used to check.
This is a classic copy end.
Unwrap them.
After we. Move forward.
The destiny Oh no.
We've checked the destination that
we can write count bytes to it,
or sorry, count elements to it.
That's you, dust.
And then if it would be eligible.
And.
Why is this not that Sentinel version?
Send copycat itsy out.
Ohh because we only have.
1st and wrong there is no.
OK, so because there's no Sentinels,
yeah, there's no signal.
Right anywhere? Yeah yeah here,
instead of saying you first plus count,
as long as we have copy my move in,
we may as well just static
cast count to size T.
Which we know is.
Non rich we know is positive.
This is a reasonable, UM.
It may end up being unnecessary if
copy memmove N is then implemented
in terms of copy memmove.
I wonder if I should note that.
What happens when it's implemented
in terms of copy memo, UM?
Or if it works?
We would essentially need to form.
At least the no, not the bite count.
We would just pass first, plus blah.
Essentially, we'd be doing that
with an extra function call.
I will note that it is probably not
necessary to make that line change if
copy Member Van turns out to be a wrapper.
Yeah, agreed. Which.
Well, we should suggest the author
that they audit for other occurrences.
OK, good idea. If Captain move in.
Is changed to just wrap, copy, remove.
This change. Would no longer be viable.
Please audit for other. Occurrences. OK.
Cool hey 130 lines down, that's like point.
5% of this entire PR?
Uh, maybe more of the the product code?
Uh, #accomplishments I.
I guess we did manage to also
review algorithm. OK, let's see.
We're our one hour in.
Let's keep going.
OK, let's actually look
at maybe a container now.
We've looked at some of the support
machinery we could start with.
The vector vector is big
because of vector bool.
We could start with
something smaller like list.
This might be a little simpler here.
Yeah, this is doing all that pen stuff.
We've got a lot of have to
provide a strong guarantee.
Vectors complicated that way.
Let's take a look at this.
This is going to be a little bit simpler.
I can get through it 96 lines OK.
I have not actually looked at the
paper yet in terms of exporting,
so let's actually look at changes to list.
Does this actually have a?
Oh, it does nice.
So no, it's not so stiff.
Custom playlist. OK.
So we get a new constructor.
List from range T,
some range and an allocator assign range.
Prepend range. Append range.
Insert range. And.
A deduction guide. OK.
So here we've got list internal
machinery being changed.
Construct range unchecked.
It's getting a Sentinel.
And instead of taking two iters,
it will now accept ITER and constant last.
We don't move from last,
so it can be top of a contest.
And we will now call pen range
unchecked by moving in first,
because that is the last mention of first.
OK, so that's good. OK.
So construct range unchecked
is being generalized.
OK, Next up.
So, uh,
let's see here Casey's guarding
this with the actual specific
feature test macro instead of just.
Which is which is a reasonable because
otherwise we would need to say.
Not just if CP Lib Concepts,
because that's a twenty thing we need to say.
If 23 in concepts and
that's annoying elsewhere,
we've simply collapsed stuff for 20 mode,
and we say if we're implementing
some feature in 20 mode,
that's specific concepts rather
than saying if Dev specific feature
test macro just say if Dev concepts
there's no reason to mention
individual feature test macros,
but now they're moving forward to 23.
It's more reasonable to say if
DEF specific feature test macro.
This will be collapsed away once we gain.
Concept support from udg.
We have got a bunch of tracking
issues and as part of that we will
check all of these individual
feature test macros and it will
become just if has CX 23 but for
now the feature test macro is fine.
I do want to make sure that
the spelling is correct.
I'm not too worried that this thing
would vanish but you can't be too sure.
OK that is the right spelling.
So if DEF CP Lib containers
ranges and if same spelling OK,
we are gaining the constructors
here that are tagged.
It is two of them because we're not
actually using default arguments and
imitating what we currently have.
So template on this internal container
compatible range thing for tea range.
List constructor from range T tag.
So this is a. Parameter.
Of the tag type being passed by value
and we don't actually care about it,
so we don't name the function parameter
at all, so that's what that means,
and then range rough graph under score range.
Yep, that's right.
If we don't have an allocator,
then construct my pair for the
compressed pair optimization empty
base optimization with zero arguments.
And then call construct range unchecked
to helper function with ranges
you begin range ranges UN range.
These are our internal helpers that will.
Get the unchecked begin and end.
That's good, and then one that takes
an allocator counts alloc Raphael.
Give that allocator to my pair and
then construct range unchecked.
Yep, that's good.
All of these new range things.
The declarations appear immediately after the
previous iterator pair equivalent things.
So generally speaking,
if you click the up arrow,
you can compare straight across.
And OK for all the constructors and opinion.
They just sign range not so much,
but insert for example.
That's very helpful advice, thank you,
yeah, so we can see that this is
being appropriately constructed here.
We don't need to verify the range
because we were given a range,
so we know we're not gonna accidentally
confuse begin and end and mismatch them,
or do wacky things.
And we are doing the unwrapping as just
phrased as you begin rather than going
to wrapped because we start with the range.
OK, so that's good insert.
This is getting unwrapped.
This is just drive by cleanup.
I don't know why Clang format
decided need to wrap this,
but this change is obviously correct.
UM, OK, now we're adding.
So we got this thing here.
Products horrible and then prepend range.
OK if def seedlip containers ranges.
Yep,
I'm not too worried about the spelling here,
because you know, test coverage
will notice these things missing.
Template on container compatible range tie R.
Void return prepend range.
Range dropper frange.
OK, I was going going back and thinking
do we need to strengthen anything?
But no,
these things are totally allocating memory,
so no possible strengthening there.
OK, going back to prepend range.
OK so.
Interesting again,
we should probably look at what's no,
this is, uh, not the same as before.
We've got this list node insert opt
2 for when we're inserting stuff.
This helps with exception safety.
This is I see this is simply a pending.
To the end of the. List.
And then we do a little bit of surgery.
Oh no, sorry it's not adding to the list,
it's attaching these nodes to this list.
Node insert up and then if it all succeeds.
We attach it to the beginning of the list,
that's this, attached before.
If anything fails,
then we haven't actually modified the
container and the list node insert up
to will handle destroying everything.
So that implies to me that we're
getting some sort of strong
exception guarantee that prepend
range is supposed to achieve.
Let's see if that's the case.
That's maybe universal
container requirements.
No, it's specific OK for.
Why is this? Why is this only
calling out pre append range here?
What about prepend?
Covered by general requirements.
Ohh is it is is it general? Yes.
Why? Why is only a penny range
being called out here then?
Now there must be something
special about a pin range. Yeah.
Multiple elements is linear.
Doesn't affect iterators
and references maybe?
But Prepend should be exactly the same.
This is just an editorial thing
that prepended rain should
have been called out here.
What? What is this?
This is a list dot modifiers.
Let's actually look at the standard.
Retainers sequence like don't
want the synopsis of what the
actual thing modifiers OK.
Go away. I want to die zoom OK.
Oh, I see. It's just a whole bunch of spam.
Preponderant pushback pushback
append range all of them, OK?
I think that I was just confused
by reading Oh yeah, here we go.
OK so actually yeah it is the whole spam
since we've got this existing stuff.
I was confused too.
By the way, you you're moving
the wording around fast enough.
I thought that was synopsis.
Still, I didn't realize these were
exactly detailed declarations.
Yeah, I thought I was looking
at synopsis up here too.
OK, so that's good.
So it is this is required to
have the strong guarantee,
which is why we're doing this insert up.
If we were simply.
Directly Prepending UM,
then it would be harder for us to unwind.
We could, UM,
but we'd be doing a lot of extra work here.
We get to make that chain,
and we only have to stitch it at
the very end to the beginning of
the list by appending essentially
the end of the beginning rather
than like repeatedly inserting.
So this is efficient.
This is good.
Yes, I see nothing wrong with this.
And this just structurally
guarantees strong exception safety,
so I don't even need to ask for.
Hey, you know, we should have,
like you know, some exception
handling tests or something.
OK, so that means the pen range
is going to look very similar
if dev people containers ranges,
and because this is Casey,
I'm pretty confident that all of
these methods are being added in
sorted order matching sorted mean
matching the order and the standard.
I can even see here it's
push front prepend range.
I guess pop front this is not the synopsis.
It should really match synopsis order.
Here we go.
Push front prepend range pop fronts.
That's why they're being inserted
in that order, so this is good.
It helps to sort of verify that the
implementation match the standard.
We did not use to be disciplined about that.
Casey is disciplined, which is great.
I have definitely been converted
over to the philosophy of, hey,
you know, that's the standard order.
Unless there's a good reason not to.
OK, so if dev containers ranges
same sort of deal I can just
compare these against each other,
append range again the insert OPP we
do the exact same thing but we attach
differently instead of attached before.
Which is. Umm? At the front of the
list here we just say attach an end.
Yep, that's good. OK, that's pen range.
And then assign unchecked.
That will help with assign range.
This is. Quite large interesting.
It's a little bit different than a sign cast.
But significantly different OK?
What are you?
Where did assign cast come from?
This is new in the sense it was added.
Like yeah this is added
like the last five years.
So as far as I'm concerned it's new.
I have pretty good memories from
like when I originally learned all
the containers like 10 years ago.
OK, this is being used over in
the unordered containers.
OK, so. It's likely this is Billy
O'Neill overhauling.
Yeah yeah, when we do a move.
Construction or sorry,
move assignment.
If we're supposed to propagate allocators,
or sorry if we're not supposed to
propagate allocators.
Then we just assign the guts in place.
Because we want to reuse as much
memory as we have basically.
Yeah, we say hey list we need to sign you and
then reinsert everything into the buckets.
OK, so that's where this is coming from.
Interesting, so we since you have a private
member function on lists that exists only
for the purpose of unordered because
we implemented the unordered containers
bidirectional link list, because why not?
Taking away constantly can assign to.
Yeah, yeah, that's really dirty things.
Look away, look away.
OK, this is doing something
significantly less evil,
but still sort of similar,
which is why it's being added at this place.
So this is now templated on Iterator
and Sentinel assign unchecked
interfirst consentino last assign
inclusive first exclusive last.
OK, consulado, my end is my prior to my head,
so that's the Sentinel pointer.
Auto old is my end next.
OK, all points to in general
the first element of the.
List or the Sentinel itself,
if the list is empty, OK,
so this is saying forever.
Attempt to reuse a node.
If first is equal to last,
that means we are now done.
We've consumed everything
from the simple range,
so indeed input sequence exhausted,
destroying the allocate any tail of
unneeded notes unchecked, erased from old.
All the way up to my end.
Which could be empty if we've exhausted
everything exactly, then return void.
OK otherwise first is not equal to last,
so we do need to assign something
if old is equal to my end.
Then we've run out of notes.
No more notes to reuse.
Append the rest so.
This is going to have strong
exception safety.
Which I'm not convinced is necessary.
We'll check that we'll append everything.
By moving in first,
because you no longer need that and
last and then attach at the end.
And then return.
OK, I'll come back to see if we
actually need this insert up,
otherwise we can reuse a node
so old points to node to reuse,
assign my Val whatever is in deara first.
Step forward the old pointer.
Which might circle around to my
end and will detect that.
And then also increment first.
OK, this all looks good.
Question here is do we actually
need and this may actually there's
no real extra expense to using
the strong exception machinery
compared to just depending stuff.
So let's see what a sign range says.
Cuz like certainly we've done work
like this doesn't actually does not
actually achieve strong exception
safety because we've already
like rewritten an existing notes.
It's not a modifier.
Just assign range.
I don't think that has any.
Let's see? OK, let's actually
search the standard.
I'm search for assign range.
Quite a bit for to catch up.
Of course it exists on many containers.
It's basic string. This is,
Oh yeah, there's no more tables.
The 4910 got rid of that horrible
container requirements table and
it's now just normal paragraphs.
This is so like a it's readable,
but it's so weird because it's
like totally different than
what we used to wade through.
So I've gotta get used to this new work.
This is the first time I had to look at it.
Umm OK, so it says assign range.
OK, here we go. Resolve.
Voyage mandates a bunch of stuff
preconditions, a bunch of stuff, effects,
replaces elements name with a copy
of each element range and validates.
Everybody also validates past the
end iterator for vector and deck.
Each iterator dereference exactly once.
There are no exception safety requirements,
which is reasonable because if you've
assigned a bunch of existing stuff,
there's no way you're unwind that.
So it's unclear to me whether
we actually need this op.
UM, could we just keep inserting nodes?
The question is, do we have a
more efficient way to do this?
I don't think so. This may actually
end up being the most convenient way.
Uh, let me see.
It's certainly not. It's not inefficient.
There's other places like in Vector where
calling the strong exception safety
stuff is theoretically less efficient.
So let's say I'm looking at lists here.
This would be where a pending.
So that's the insert one.
We would have to call insert to end,
but that's an arbitrary one and that
inserted end has a lot of logic.
There's append N.
We could do repeated.
Essentially it's a repeated pushbacks.
Uhm, or place backs really what
is in place back look like.
And place back inserted end.
Emplace give it my head.
And it's got that special return thing.
There's some place implemented. Is it above?
It's probably below. I want kiss.
Place. OK, if we in place we
actually use an in place up as well,
and then we transfer.
So I see no advantage to
trying to avoid the insert off.
We should just use it, agreed.
OK, great assign. Ohh interesting,
so our list assign used to actually
go through that assign cast which.
Existed primarily for the unordered
containers, now it exists purely
for the unordered containers and we
don't need to sign cast reference.
Yeah, that's weird.
Casting existing notes to target
ref to try to reuse stuff.
Yeah, I I like this change.
Get rid of internal calls to assign cast.
Leave it only for the inner containers.
Assign unchecked. Rooting stuff
through that makes a lot more sense,
and this exists for all standard modes.
Yes, I like this a lot and then
we just unwrap first and last.
Why do we not?
Why do we not validate the range here?
We just unwrapped that seems wrong.
Just saying the same thing with
my my mic muted.
We don't verify these.
Yeah, that seems wrong.
We're we're usually pretty
consistent about ADL verifying.
I think this is pretty.
Yeah, but we've already
unwrapped a sign cast does not.
It assumes they're unchecked.
I think it's just a bug. Yeah.
Pre existing bug, but I'll fix it here.
OK, yeah, we don't want to do
too many unrelated cleanups,
but I mean here we're just
reimplementing or assign.
It is reasonable to fix this bug here,
especially because it's doesn't
involve like a lot of control
flow transformation or something.
It's just atomising verify pre-existing.
Oh wow, we weren't. Umm?
ADL verifying this range before.
Unwrapping UM, not sure if it's easy to find.
In theory it might be possible
to find other ones.
It would be like to get on wraps.
I could spell properly
with casing. Like this?
Yeah wow, we got a bunch,
so we're essentially involved like scan
through every currence and look for 88
L verify range on some previous line.
It's like you're looking at this one.
Ah, but we have helpers.
Get unwrapped, unverified,
says hey, we haven't actually
verified this thing yet,
so we'd really want like
just get unwrapped by itself.
Yes, so just making sure.
Hey, you know, does everybody verify?
And here it does.
It looks like we do most of the time.
Like this one, suspicious,
so I'm not actually sure how
widespread this problem is.
There could be there could be others.
I'm not gonna go scan the whole STL,
but I'm like in other containers we do like.
Here's deck, assign deck,
assign does verify range and then unwrap
so it looks like just list maybe.
Yeah, even forward list is
decent about a sign verify,
so hopefully it's just isolated.
Doesn't demand a whole
still wide audit. This is.
Yep, here's the one we found in list.
That's the the bad one.
OK yeah, well one line fixed up is fine.
OK. Find all the bugs.
Uh, Next up maybe we'll get through list.
Uh, let's see.
We're a sign range.
Let's go back to the actual paper.
Assign range temp if dev containers ranges.
Yep, template container compatible range RNG.
Void assign Range Range Rover Range
we can directly call sign unchecked
because we know the range is good,
we don't need to validate anything.
OK, so that's the sign range.
Here. Insert. This is unwrapping.
I'm OK with this moderate level
of Clang format unwrapping.
I don't know why clang format.
Oh, I see it's a common detach.
It's not a pure unwrap.
Yeah, it's fine.
I do know that in 1000 line PR.
Maybe this could have been separated out,
but it's it's fine,
there's not merge conflicts.
If I see a lot of that,
I'll start grinding my teeth.
If Dev CPV containers ranges OK,
insert range.
This method here template container
compatible range TR iterator insert
range take constant iterator position.
We call that where? And.
Range rapper frange Yep. OK.
So if iterator debug levels two,
we have a check.
Here I should be looking at
something pre-existing here.
Yeah, because it's going to look like this.
We should verify that the where's container
is equal to the address of my data.
Otherwise list insert iterator outside range.
Yep, usual comment OK or assertion.
And then we have a range
we don't need verify.
Let's make an insert up with
our allocator appending done.
Check you begin, you end and then.
Make it or attach before.
Yep, exactly the same, it's good.
And then C tab class template arm
deduction if Dev cglib containers ranges.
We are template on ranges input range R&amp;G.
Class allocator defaults to
stood allocator of ranges.
Range of value TR and G.
And we've got a constraint here.
This is going to be.
Standard Y If you're a guide
that's templated on allocator,
you actually need to be allocator ish.
That's what everybody else is constrained on.
Like if I can expand this.
Yeah here enable if.
Is allocator alloc value.
OK, in zero do we have another allocator V?
Or is it only a struct?
Looks like it's only a struct.
OK, that's fine.
List from range T range ref ref.
Alec by value is equal to Alec pren pren.
Deduce list of ranges,
range of value TR and that allocator.
OK good that's list.
Yeah, we got through a container.
OK, let's see it is.
525I think this may be a good
place to pause the review.
We may be coming back to this next week.
Because we've got all the other
containers to go through and
then a whole bunch of test code.
Hopefully most of the containers
except for vector will look similar.
Ish vector special because of its
strong exception safety guarantees,
but I'm hoping that these change the product
changes are now going to be more mechanical.
Yeah, deck is always special
because of the proxy.
I'm just sort of go OK.
We got some guard stuff here.
OK, there is a fair amount
of container surgery fun.
Yeah, I think if even if I start
forward list forward list actually does
look pretty similar to list. Yeah,
I don't think I can do that in five minutes.
OK, I think this is a good stopping point.
I will submit a very very partial review.
Five out of 117 files viewed,
but we got a chance to look at how one
container is implemented and the overall
feature, so hopefully that was useful.
If you have any questions let us know.
Otherwise we'll see you on
the next open code review.
Thanks for watching.